- Hi everyone.
Sal here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the homeroom live stream.
Actually, I think this
is the first of the year.
Hopefully everyone had a good New Year's,
considering the circumstances
and is enjoying 2021,
given the circumstances.
We have a very exciting show today.
I think someone who needs
really no introduction,
but Melinda Gates, co-chair
of the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and author of Moment of Lift:
How Empowering Women Changes the World.
So start thinking of questions
that you could put in
on YouTube and Facebook.
We'll try to get to as many of
those questions as possible.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I will give my standard announcements.
A reminder that Khan Academy,
we are a not-for-profit organization
that's funded through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
And donations at all levels
really make a huge difference.
I also want to make a shout
out to several organizations
that stepped up when they realized
that the world was
depending on Khan Academy
even more during COVID, so special thanks
to Bank of America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and General Motors,
but we continue to need more help.
So anything you can do
is very much appreciated.
And last but not least,
want to remind everyone
that you can get a version
of this live stream
in podcast form, wherever
you get your podcasts
at Homeroom with Sal the podcast.
With that, I'm so excited
to introduce Melinda Gates,
author of Moment of Lift:
How Empowering Women Changes
the World, and co-chair
of the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
Melinda, great to see you.
- Hi Sal.
Thanks for having me.
- Well, there's so much
that I could talk about,
and you cover a lot of this in your book
and there's a lot of work that
you've done beyond the book.
Maybe a good place to start
would be with the book.
Why did you decide that now is
a good time to write a book?
And what are your hopes for it?
- Well, I wrote this book
and introduced it in 2019,
and now we're coming out
just now with the paperback.
And I wrote it at the time
because I had been lucky enough
to travel the world
because of the Foundation.
And I'd met so many women who
had really animated my life
and called me to action.
And I felt if I could tell their stories
it might call the world to action.
And when I wrote this book,
I think we, as a community
thought we were on our way
towards gender equality.
And now here we are in
the middle of a pandemic
in early 2021 and women
have really been set back
in the United States
and all over the globe.
So we have all a lot
more work ahead of us.
- And what's been surprising, you know,
when I saw the book and
I started reading it,
I expected to hear a lot of
the stories of your travels,
the work that y'all have been
doing with the Foundation.
And there's definitely that,
but what's been really interesting,
it's also a very personal book where you
kind of thread in your own experience
trying to balance the
different pulls on your time
from trying to be a great mother,
trying to have a great
career at the same time,
and kind of relating that to, you know,
a general theme of women around the world
have all of these things that
they're trying to balance.
- Yes, I thought it was
important to include
my personal story.
I mean, to begin with,
you know, I do live a life
of extreme privilege now, but growing up,
I grew up in a very middle-class family
in the United States.
And I think no matter whether you're in
a low income country, middle
income or high income,
women face a lot in their lives
that we just don't talk about.
And I thought it was important
to talk about my own journey
and my own struggles with
balancing being a mom,
which I absolutely wanted to
be and am, and a working woman.
And I tried to then highlight
how that also is similar
for so many women around the globe
who don't even have the
resources that I have
to get some extra support and help.
- So I want to go into
actually both of those,
and I'm sure there'll be a
lot of questions to that,
but first when we're
talking about helping women
around the world, and obviously there's
the pre-COVID context in
which you wrote the book,
and then what you're able to see both
in the broader kind of, you
could say industrializing world
and in the in the industrialized world,
what COVID stresses or putting on,
what do you see as, you know,
if you want people to walk away
with the handful of things that are
the real challenges facing women
that we really have to
address, what are they to you?
- They are, to me, the
barriers that hold women back
in society that we so
often don't talk about,
harassment and abuse, whether
at home or in the workplace.
The other big barrier, quite frankly,
is this child care work, this
unpaid labor that women do
in their homes every single day.
No matter where you are in the world,
women do more unpaid
work than their husband
or their spouse does.
And that keeps them often from
being fully in the workforce
and being fully present.
And then there are many things
we can do to accelerate women
in key, key industries,
making sure we get money
in their hands, accelerate
them in finance,
accelerate them in the tech
sector in the United States,
accelerate them in policy
making and political positions,
because until you have women
with a seat at the table
using their full voice and
decision-making authority,
we will never have sound policies
that benefit all of society.
And those are imperatives for us
if we're going to really
move forward as a world.
- You know, there's a lot in that.
You know, there's a fairness argument,
which is a very strong one.
There's the argument you just made,
which is this argument around,
you really need a diversity
of viewpoints around the
decision-making table,
especially if it's going to affect people
of different viewpoints,
but you know, your book you refer to,
and this definitely
struck a chord with me,
you talk about the study in Bangladesh,
which is where my family
originally comes from,
where they're able to
actually to some degree
run an experiment where women
were more in the driver's seat
of things like family
planning and what that led to.
It didn't just lead to better
outcomes for those women.
If you could talk a little bit about that,
because I think that's a
very super poignant example
for why it's so important
to invest in women.
- Yeah, thank you for that question, Sal,
because I think so often
we don't talk about
family planning or contraceptives.
And yet when you look
in the United States,
what has allowed women to go to college
and to get a degree and
to work in the workforce?
It's being able to decide
when, whether and how often
to have children.
So in Bangladesh, as you
referenced in the 1970s
the longest global health
study that's ever been run
were two different sets of villages,
where one set had full
access to contraceptives.
Women were educated about their bodies,
all types of methods of contraceptives,
and then they used them,
and other villages that
didn't have access.
And what they found over this long study
was that in the villages
where contraceptives
were readily available and used,
the families were healthier,
the children were healthier,
the children were better educated,
and the families overall were wealthier.
And that's because the moms
and dads could space the births
of their children and feed
and educate each one of them
and start down that path to prosperity
before they chose to have another child.
And that it makes a profound difference
in terms of unlocking the cycle of poverty
for a woman and for her family.
- Well, you talk about that.
I mean, when you point it out,
it's something we so take for granted.
You mention in the book how you were able
to essentially plan things out.
It made me reflect on
my wife and my journey
where you know, my wife also,
she's more educated than I am,
she went to med school and
that for our first child,
we kind of said, okay, there's that year
right after residency, before you start.
Okay, let's have our first child then.
And that ability, which
we take for granted
is not something that's commonplace
for most of human history,
and unfortunately,
in a lot of part of the
world is still not expected.
And so it's really, when
you're able to space it out,
a family can have resources,
they can invest in their children.
And then obviously I can imagine
that has follow-on effects.
Are there other, you know,
it seems like that's
one of the top things,
just the ability to have control
and be able to space things out
and make sure that the resources.
Are there other big things that you think
folks should know about, and, you know,
folks being everyone listening,
people in government,
people in the philanthropic sector,
that are high leverage
points for empowering,
not just women, but because
you're empowering them,
the communities that
they're they're part of?
- Well, certainly two things
I would say: educating a girl.
When a girl has access to
school and to a good education,
she makes completely different
decisions about her life.
And when she has access to those new ideas
and that new thinking,
she also delays, usually,
when she gets married and
when she has children.
That again, has a profound
effect on a community,
not just at a community level,
but at a regional level
and at a country level.
And it's why finally, in the last 10 years
so many presidents and prime ministers
actually finally show up at the UN
and talk about girls' education,
getting girls into school and keeping them
all the way through at
least secondary school.
So that is a really important
factor, is girls education,
just like boys.
And the other one is
getting economic means
in a woman's hand.
So all over the world, one of
the things that we now have,
of course, are phones.
and even if you don't have a smartphone,
but you have access to
an old plastic phone,
there are governments all over the world,
India, Bangladesh, many
others, Tanzania, Kenya,
where they're making
sure that women and men
can save a dollar a day,
$2 a day on their phones.
So they actually have a bank account,
so that when the school
fees come due for the child,
or there's a health shock in the family,
or they need to purchase food
the woman has money of her own,
that is not her husband's money.
And that is vitally important,
because it empowers her in the family.
And she is often the one who decides
who's going to eat
first, second, and third,
or who's going to go
to the medical facility
or who's going to help pay for the tuition
when it comes due at the school.
So a woman, when she
has money in her hands,
she can get out of an abusive situation.
She can invest in a small business.
She can make different decisions
for herself and her children.
Money is power and it makes a difference
for women's own power and influence.
- It makes a ton of sense.
You know, it leads to a natural question,
When I read some of the stats, the studies
on these various dimensions,
it seems like a no-brainer
that more of the world
should be focused on this,
should be investing.
I know there's been a lot of progress
over the last several decades,
but it also makes me
wonder why weren't people
already doing that?
You know, the role of why
haven't governments, you know,
why has there had to been such an emphasis
on the philanthropic sector,
and then maybe take the other side.
You in the book mentioned when
you first met Hans Rosling,
famous data visualizer.
How he was skeptical.
I think he said something like,
American billionaires
are gonna mess things up.
And you hear that more and
more in the public narrative
of people saying, well
philanthropy sounds good,
but we're not so sure or
maybe this is too much power
in the hands of a few people.
Where do you see that balance?
Where's the role of philanthropy
and what's your sense of
how you make people realize
that there's actually a lot of value here?
- So let me start with
the second question,
which is philanthropy's role.
I think philanthropy does its best
when it understands that
it is part of an ecosystem.
What you need is philanthropy, government,
private sector, that is
businesses, civil society,
all working together to
benefit the world and society.
What can philanthropic money do
that some of the others can't?
They can take risks
where there is no market,
so a business won't enter it,
or where the government
doesn't want to take the risk,
with the citizens' money.
It can try new things.
It can further new ideas.
And if those things prove out,
then it's up to government to fund them
and to spread those ideas.
So to your question though,
the earlier one was,
why was it a decade ago when, you know,
15 years ago I happened to be at the UN
or other places with other global leaders,
no one talked about girls, first of all.
Girls were not on the agenda.
Women were only on the agenda
when it came to their maternal health.
prime ministers and presidents didn't talk
about women and girls, other than that.
Well, why is that?
It's because we run in
a society where males
run the top of society.
They run the political
bodies, they run quite often
the social media platforms,
they run the newspapers.
And so you have to make
sure that you actually make
extra investments to help women rise up
into those positions of power,
because if you don't have a diverse
slate of people at the table,
that is in our own country
people of color, women and men,
you then don't get a diverse
representation of society,
and so you make government
policy based on what you know,
but if that comes from say
a group of just white men,
they don't see the full view of society
that a woman or a person of color
with their lived
experience would have seen.
And thus you don't build
into society the places
that will unlock opportunities
for women and people of color.
And that's why I am such a big proponent
of making sure we create pathways
for women into the key, key industries,
such as politics or finance or tech,
because of how pervasive
and how much those areas
run our society and our globe.
- I couldn't agree more.
And, you know, the question I asked,
obviously, in full
disclosure, many folks know
your foundation has been,
one of kind of the founding
sponsors of Khan Academy.
So obviously, I have some biases here
that I should have a whole disclaimer for,
but Khan Academy would not exist
without the philanthropic sector.
And it absolutely, even when
my friends were skeptical,
why does Khan Academy even exist?
Shouldn't it be for profit or
shouldn't it be government?
It's exactly in that zone
where it needs to move fast
and innovate, but it
needs to operate on values
that may be market forces,
which I'm normally a big fan of,
might not lead to the outcomes we want.
And that's just a small example,
but some of the work that
y'all have been doing
with malaria, with polio, with diarrhea,
some of these things that
shouldn't be killing anyone
for the last several decades,
were killing thousands
or in some cases, millions of people.
I mean, both you and Bill,
I think are very humble
about how many millions,
literally millions
of lives you saved and
arguably it should be
part of government, but without
the philanthropic sector
there I don't think, these
aren't vanity projects.
I don't think any of
that would have happened.
You know, one question,
a lot of questions coming
in on social media,
I'll get to some of them.
I've been using my privilege
to take all my questions,
but this question, is
related to that last point.
It's from YouTube, from chillax.
What do you think you have achieved
by working and collaborating with women
in different countries?
And, you know, I do wonder that.
You and Bill, you go on
a lot of these trips,
you go on a lot of trips,
you visit villages.
You're really in places that
many of us have never been to.
My family is from Bangladesh.
I think you've gone into more
of the real rural villages
of Bangladesh than I,
or many members of my
family have ever been to.
What do you learn from those trips
that you might not have
appreciated before?
- Well, I think it's fundamental to travel
and to listen and to learn,
because I think, we could come in
with our Western point of view of,
Oh, you need this for your child,
or this is the way to do things
because we do it that
way in the US or Europe.
When in fact you listen to the locals,
they have very good reasons
for doing what they do,
and they have seen more death
and disability than we have.
They can tell you what might work
or what the barriers
are that hold them back.
You can come in for instance,
with the very best vaccine
or new tool, let's say for malaria,
but if the village elder
who makes the decision
won't let that tool be taken up,
it's going to go nowhere.
And so for women, what I have learned
is that you need to go in, sit
down with them in their homes
and where they gather
in the village market
or on a local mat, talk
with them, and the men,
eventually let the men wander
away back to the fields
or to their business, and then you hear
the truth of women's lives.
And you hear what they're up against,
what lengths they will go to,
how they do take their meager
means and feed their children,
and you learn that women
are incredibly resilient.
And so one of the things
I've been fortunate enough
to be involved or help lead
is this effort on family planning
because so many women have told me,
I've heard of those tools.
We used to have them in my village.
I don't have them now.
And I have six children.
I cannot have a seventh.
I cannot feed these children.
And so I've helped lead
this family planning effort
because there are 200 million women
asking us for contraceptives,
and we need to educate
women about contraceptives
and their bodies if they
don't know about them.
And if they do, make sure
they have access to them
so they can voluntarily decide
if they want to use them
and if and when to have children.
- And where do you think this is going?
I mean, you've talked about
a lot of the good work
that's already happened, but it also is
kind of painting a picture.
There's a lot of important
work that needs to be done.
What do you see for yourself,
or I would say for the broader sector,
what needs to be the priorities
for the next five or 10 years?
And what is an outcome we can
be hopeful about in 10 years
and maybe one that we should be afraid of
if we don't take action?
- Yes, well, I will have to be frank
that this COVID-19 pandemic
has set us back enormously
in global health and global development.
You know, where poverty
was on the decline,
we're now seeing poverty on the rise.
Where we were making huge
inroads on contraceptives,
for instance, they're now
going to be 15 million
unintended pregnancies this
year alone, we estimate,
because of the lack of contraceptives.
So the global health
community will have a lot
of building back to do to make sure
that vaccination rates stay up,
to make sure children
are fed and kept alive.
But some of the things
we can be hopeful about,
I think do come from these new tools.
The fact that so many people
around the world have a
cell phone in their hands.
You know, information is power.
Money is power.
We can give them life-saving
information on their phone.
We can start to hook them
up in their local community
with telemedicine, especially
if the health services
just aren't there or
aren't functioning well,
which is true in many
countries around the world.
And so I think these new digital tools
give us opportunities.
As long as we get them out
equitably into women's hands,
we teach women about the internet
and we make sure that they have access.
And so it means we have
to do special programming
just for women so that they do
actually get these new tools,
or if there's a new seed available
that's drought resistant or pest resistant
against climate change, we
have to go the extra mile
to not just get it in the hands of men,
but to get it in the hands of women, too,
So they can get a bigger yield
and get more income off their farm
because most women in the world,
their work is in the informal
sector and they're farmers.
- And you touched on that
in that last statement.
What do you see as the role?
Obviously, there's a
role for policy makers,
there's a role for philanthropy.
There's a huge role for
women, obviously, in this.
What do you see as, how
do we change the culture
or what's going on in the men's minds?
And, I'm curious about a lot of places
we've been talking about where even things
like family planning, you
can't take for granted.
But then after that, I
have a few questions about
how do we do it in a lot
of our lives as well?
- Well, I think to change
culture you really have
to start where people are
and you have to listen to them
about why they have certain beliefs,
why they do things the way they do them.
And only over time with a
lot of trust and discussion,
can you start to introduce new ideas,
and then people have to
decide for themselves
do they want to take up those new ideas.
Yes, you can push down
with top down policy.
For instance, a good child marriage law,
but communities have to accept that
and decide they're not going
to do child marriage again.
Even in the United States,
things that used to be acceptable
before in my mom's
generation, we don't expect,
we don't say those are the norms today.
And so we spread things and
ideas through our networks
and then we influence one another.
So for instance, today,
you'd be pretty hard pressed
to find too many women
smoking during pregnancy.
And yet when Jackie
Kennedy was the First Lady
of the United States, there's
pictures of her smoking.
Well, we came to learn that is
not good for babies or moms,
but those ideas there
had to be good policy,
but we had to have good ideas spread.
That's how you spread new ideas
in all kinds of communities
about issues for women, about
breaking down men's thinking
about what women's roles can or should be,
and even for us about what ideas we have
about people of color in our own country
or indigenous people.
That's how you change hearts
and minds, and it takes time,
but it can be done.
- No, and on that,
you've touched on this in
your own personal life,
and actually I wanted some
help with with mine as well,
is, you talk about this notion,
which is absolutely true,
and we started there that,
whether we're talking about
a village in Bangladesh,
or we're talking about a two
income professional family
in Seattle or Silicon Valley,
some of this issue of women
are disproportionately taking,
doing a lot of what has to
happen in the house and at home,
even when someone hypothetically
is a rheumatologist.
My wife's a rheumatologist.
My question is, and it's true.
My wife's a rheumatologists.
I obviously spend my time
working on Khan Academy.
You know, in theory, I would love
for there not to be this bias
or this uneven playing field,
but my wife, you know,
we never argue, but I hear some
families argue about things.
How much, who does what?
One thing that I've thought about,
do we just have unrealistic expectations
on both men and women that essentially,
we want to be super parents,
which could take 90% of your time.
We want to be super workers,
which could take 90% of our time.
And so if you have two people,
each three jobs that take 90%,
you're trying to have 270%
with only 200% of time.
I'm curious how you and
Bill have navigated that.
- Well, I think in all of our homes,
we have to look at who does what,
and we have to say, what are our values?
And what do we want as
a family and a society.
And I think sometimes in the United States
we've gotten it a bit wrong
where we value work so much,
as opposed to saying, wait
a minute, in our homes
we all know we care about our families,
but how do we balance society to make sure
there are good childcare
options out there,
good childcare infrastructure?
How do we make sure in our homes
we have the tough conversations
about why do we both men and women,
myself included, have
gender normative ideas
about who takes out the
garbage, or who does the dishes,
or who gets through to go
to their computer first
after dinner versus helping
the kids with homework?
We have to actually look
at all those tasks and say,
how do we redistribute them?
And are there times in each of our careers
where maybe the woman's
career goes first for a while
and the man helps take care of
the kids a bit more at home,
and maybe then there's a time
where his career goes forward,
And she takes care of
the kids more at home?
There are ways to blend and balance this,
but we do need better policy
making in the United States.
We need a paid family
medical leave policy.
We're the only industrialized
nation that doesn't have one.
Only 20% of our workers
get maternity leave.
That's insane.
And so we need to have good policy
and we need to have honest conversations
in our homes if we're
going to change things.
- No, couldn't agree more.
And I could talk for hours about this,
because I think it's a
fascinating subject, actually,
whether it's in the
village or in the city.
In the time we have left
Melinda, any parting thoughts?
Especially to those
who have been watching,
We have students
watching, we have parents,
we have people of all ages,
but I also think about
it, especially to the men,
not even view some of these
things, we call them chores,
'cause there might be chores at home,
but actually to your point,
embrace some of these things.
Some of my best moments that
I'll never regret in my life
are when I am able to help
with give my kids a bath.
They're a little older
now, so that'd be awkward,
but when I wasn't able
to give them a bath,
or clean the house or whatever else.
What messages would you
want everyone to take away,
both from your book or just in general?
- I would say, we need to look
at all of our norms in society.
Whether I've met people in
a remote village in Senegal,
I've had men tell me who
have taken on more chores
or made some changes, normative
changes in their family.
And I'll eventually get them alone
and I'll say, well, why did you do that?
And they said, because that work is hard
that my wife was doing.
My wife was tired.
When she's happier, I'm happier
and my whole family is happier.
And, in the US we kind of have a saying,
happy wife, happy life.
I think it's true.
If men and women are
happier in their homes,
our children are happier
and more balanced,
and we can go out and
do what we want to do.
So what I want to say to
people is it's possible.
We just have to really
re-look at things and decide
what is it that we want.
And what I know is that society
is going to be better off
when we have women taking
their equal place to men,
not just in their homes, but at all places
that decisions are made
and we all need to work towards equality.
In the United States where
208 years away from equality.
We sometimes think, oh, we're 50 or 60.
No, we're 208 years away.
So we have to make these
decisions in our home
if they're going to have ripple effects
in our community and in our world.
And I know it's possible.
It sound like you're doing
it and thinking about it
in your own home, Sal,
and that's fabulous.
- No, we talk about it a lot.
So, it's a real thing, but it's inspiring
and it's good to know that,
in some ways it's comforting to know
that you and Bill deal with
some of the same problems
that we're trying, some
of the same tensions,
but I could talk for hours
about this and your book,
which is incredible.
I really encourage people to take a look.
It's out in paperback today,
where it talks about, I mean, just a lot
of really interesting
things that I think everyone
needs to be informed about men and women.
Melinda, thank you so much.
Thank you so much for the years of support
for what we're doing at Khan Academy
and frankly changing the lives
of millions around the
world and setting an example
with things like the Giving Pledge
of kind of, I think, a new generation,
a new type of philanthropy that I think
is changing the world.
So thank you so much.
- Well, thanks for having
me on your home room.
I wish you'd been in my home
room when I was growing up.
All the best to you.
- See you, thank you so much.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
That was a wonderful conversation.
As you could imagine, we could
have spoken for hours more.
So much in that.
But I really do encourage
you all to take a look
at Moment of Lift.
I was telling Melinda before we went on,
there's a lot that I expected to see
that I found very insightful
about how do you affect global
health and empower women,
but there's a lot of really,
I would say almost intangible
and very personal stories about Melinda
and her journeys and her
struggles, which I think,
I found a lot in that, as well.
So definitely take a look at that.
I'll also let y'all know
we're going to have another
Homeroom live stream
tomorrow with Jennifer Doudna
who is a 2020 Nobel Prize
in chemistry winner.
So we're going to geek out
hard tomorrow in chemistry.
So encourage you all to come.
And actually, if you want
do a little bit of research
ahead of time, if you need a
little background knowledge,
I know a good website called Khan Academy
to make sure your your
chemistry is boned up
to be able to talk with
a Nobel prize winner.
So look forward to that and
I'll see everyone tomorrow.
(cheery music)